have you guys seen where video games are
already at with this stuff dude it's
crazy it used to be
Super Mario Brothers Mario goes in the
castle and text appears thank you for
saving me but the prince is in another
castle that was the extent of NPC
communication with you it Advanced two
games now where you can choose to say
something and then a voice actor
scripted line will speak that's a great
idea let's get the mission underway and
you're like cool now with text to voice
and predictive language models video
games have already started you're
wearing a headset you walk up to the NPC
and you say something like hey idiot
ugly I want to buy some soda and the a
the NPC goes who are you calling an
idiot if you want to buy something be
polite a generated predictive response
we are we are years away from people
saying I no longer want to live in
reality I'm going to go into this
universe where I can tune out and you're
going to be sitting in your living room
talking to fake people